truthfully like florida but being honest
wasn't at the top of my list
okay my hair is not doing well here i'm
just gonna put that out there i knew
that i was like i don't know the heat
the humidity i don't think it's gonna be
my friend i'm not a beach girl i'm not
somebody who as you may notice you're
like chad you look like casper yeah and
i will look like casper six months from
now i'm not a beach girl i don't you
know hang out in the sun
um jorge behind me is like get some sun
girl really i mean just a little
wouldn't hurt you know you thought it
jorge you didn't say it out loud but you
jorge's not miked or he would have said
it kai's like kaz you're you're you're
pretty happy he probably said chica yeah
he was like a little bit of sun just a
little bit won't hurt you my dad's at
home he's like a little vitamin d just a
small amount my dad's in new york right
now
he's more tan than i am and let me tell
you something i'm sicilian so if i want
to be tan girlfriend's going to be tan
quickly but
you know the sun damage anyway
um florida wasn't at the top of my list
truly i came here because i saw a
fighter i saw a fighter in desantis and
i said you know what
i want to bring my kid to a place where
i know
that his freedoms are safeguarded where
i know that someone is standing up to
these curriculums in school that are
looking to indoctrinate i want to send
my kid to school to learn how to read
write and do math i don't want to send
him to school so that a teacher can tell
him what causes he's supposed to be an
advocate for i don't need him coming
home with pins and labels saying mommy i
need to endorse this or else i'm going
to be in trouble no no thank you that's
not school that's called an
indoctrination camp and i felt like
florida was a place and i still feel
like florida is a place where free
thinking people are welcome
so that's why i'm here and that's why i
thought it would be a great place to do
the show that we're gonna do
what you saw here today
that's a taste of where we're going
um
maybe some shows will have one topic
maybe some shows will have 15 topics i'm
going to interview some people and
expose some stuff in health and wellness
that's not political at all i'm going to
expose some stuff in health and wellness
that's very political and i'm going to
have people on here that are unafraid
that are fearless and that are gonna say
what they can't say
elsewhere and that they won't say
elsewhere because they're not gonna get
a fair exchange of ideas if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]